[Music]
Ducky's auto repair and body shop in
Martinsburg West Virginia for all the
noise in Washington DC here the Robert
mother report barely registered as an
issue except as a Democrat driven
destruction two years of this going on
and they chomping at the bits and then
when it comes out not their way they're
not happy with it and I'm pleased there
is now a bit of a political row about
whether or not the public is going to
get to see the full model report do you
want to see it I could care less what am
I going to see I'm a commoner you know
I'm a businessman I mean it says I mean
if the Attorney General says it's good
the Assistant Attorney General says it's
good they wrote they wrote the summary
of the report so it's over Bucky's
employees feel the same were you ever
concerned that the president or people
around him had been colluding with
Russia Donald Trump yeah there was no
doubt in my mind that what he did was a
legitimate he's free and clear I think
we should be done with it and just leave
it at that and going to more important
issues that this country is you know
involved in let the man just do his job
Sports Trump let it just let him do his
job these are not isolated opinions in
America's heartland the president enjoys
broad support West Virginia handed
Donald Trump his largest margin of
victory in 2016
many voters here supported him precisely
because he was such a defiant outsider
so willing to do battle with the
establishment and so the Mulla report is
only going to strengthen that image
at Marymount horse farm Murray Fogarty
considers what might happen next she is
a Democrat rare in these parts and hope
the special counsels investigation would
land a blow that never came is it
possible that the Miller report outcome
is going to help the Republicans yes it
is because our country loves a victim
and if they feel he's been victimized
then they will definitely stand behind
him they've already his numbers have
already gone up yeah I do think it's
helped in this part of the country
Murray is relatively alone in her berm
use meant the gulf between Democrats and
Republicans growing ever wider as the
next election looms Hannah Thomas Peter
Sky News in West Virginia